how can we quickly square the numbers
that are close to the powers of 10 let's
see a few examples
998 squared the base of this number is
1000 because it is close to 1 000 first
let us calculate 998 minus 1000 which
gives us negative 2. now let us divide
the answer into two parts on the left we
write 998 plus negative 2 and on the
right remember that the number of digits
will be equal to the number of zeros
which is 3 in this case so on the right
we write the square of the difference
that is negative to the whole squared so
on the left we get 996 and on the right
we get zero zero four so here we have
our answer
the base of this number is one thousand
and after some calculations we get this
answer
using this trick can you answer 1003
squared and tell us in the comment
section
for more such interesting math tricks
please subscribe to our youtube channel